From the moment we were brought here in bondage
in 1619, Black life in this country
has been defined by hard work,
and our labor has generated
success stories
that deserve to be celebrated.
Commonly, people refer to “The 1619 Project”
as a history, but it's not a history.
It really is talking about America today.
“The 1619 Project” is a six-part docuseries
that explores all aspects of American life
through the lens of slavery.
Each episode has its own story
arc and has its own particular beat in history.
We were told that by virtue
of our bondage,
we would never be American,
but it was by virtue of our bondage
that we became the most American of all.
The very first episode is “Democracy,”
and it really talks
about how Black Americans have been
the primary democratizing force
over generations in this country.
I want to be able to look back and say,
I did this so that you didn't have to.
That's what legacy is all about.
The “Race” episode deals with the idea
that race is a construct
that was made up to divide
the powerful from the powerless.
This is a power hierarchy,
whether we're talking about
where you live, what kind of job
you can have, and just in general
how you're valued in society.
The “Music” episode is about
how Black music is in
every aspect of American life.
There's a whole cultural experience
that is fascinating and foreign
to White people.
They are drawn to this music.
The “Capitalism”
episode looks at the particular
brutality of the exploitation of labor.
I'm looking at the names of people
and their value in the slave ledgers,
and they're being listed
literally next to a pig or cow.
It's something I'll never forget.
The episode around fear examines
the fear of Black men
and how that still plays out today.
Jefferson was always worried
about the revolution
of the wheel of fortune - that is,
we're on top now, but this thing can spin.
The “Justice” episode makes the argument
that there is a great moral
and financial debt
that is owed to Black Americans.
You are calling for reparations.
What is the total that would be owed?
I've seen estimates as high as $14
trillion.
That's a big number.
It’s a big debt, though.
It is a big debt.
I think people are going to be compelled
and surprised and hurt
but also come away with a newfound respect
for the role
that Black Americans
have played in this country.
We are still here and we're still fighting,
as long as there’s life,
we're going to have hope.
What if America understood after four hundred years
that Black people have never been
the problem
but the solution?